what's up everyone and welcome to the
operation gramma sky full reveal my name
is Justin Kruger community developer on
Rainbow six siege and today we are about
to go over all the details of our two
new operators maverick and clash and we
have a new rework in the works coming to
you very soon the rework of Hanford and
to help me break down all of these
details please welcome our two panelists
jeremy Doucet level designer and a
million low maze game designer how you
guys doing I'm doing good man hell yeah
I'm doing fantastic these events have
been amazing the games have been amazing
mainly how was your event been so far
data week has been incredible it's
insane to see the crowd see the team to
deliver they have it's fantastic it's
such a good time the crowd has been
incredible this entire event they've
been going crazy and I know they cannot
wait to get into some of this content
that we got coming up and so let's get
right into it without further ado let's
take a look at Hereford base our rework
hair furred base Jeremy let's uh for
those people that don't know what a
rework is what exactly is a rework a
rework is an opportunity for the team to
go through and look at legacy maps that
we've built and in this case Hereford
was the first map that we actually built
and prototype the game on and look at
the problems and rework it from the
start you know in this case it's a brand
new map if you look at the old hair a
foot now that's up on the screen and
look at the new Hereford we've
completely redone it from the ground up
completely redone it so it's way
different than what we've introduced
last season with the map buff this is a
new map base bottom line I mean it's a
little familiar but it's it's really new
players that know siege and know the
game will recognize it they'll recognize
the thematics the Spitfires the control
tower and there and the shooting range
but the inside is game you know it's a
slightly bigger floorplan that it was
before with more rotation options and
more verticality so we've gone through
and made a brand new map for the
community right and so
you mentioned some of the issues with
the old hair fur base what are what were
some of those issues and why did you
need to fix them for this map obviously
it's a little bit old now it was the
first map ever made but now it's you're
going in and changing the guts of it
basically the problem with the old
Hereford was the destruction needed to
be updated and also there was only one
really viable bomb site which was down
in the basement so you know when you're
playing a game and it's always the same
bomb site same bombs and the other bomb
sites don't get used it's no fun to play
so what we've done now is for bomb sites
more stairs more verticality more
destruction and just made it so it's
actually a much more viable and much
more fun map to play as a level designer
do you feel as though that's one of the
biggest challenges and most important
aspects of your job to see that variety
in bomb site selection in order to have
a balanced map you have to make the make
sure that bomb sites are completely
viable you don't want one that's
slightly overpowered because then once
it goes ranked or pro they'll always
pick that bomb site you know but now
they have to play all the bomb sites but
the real thing is you want viable bomb
sites you want variety in the map and
you do really want it to be balanced and
to play well as much as humanly possible
a really key thing that we were talking
about last time you're up here in May at
the Atlantic City finals was rotations
and for villa rotations were integrated
into that from the beginning but the old
Fairford had some issues with rotations
and what have you guys done to resolve
some of that you mentioned the stairs as
well but tell us a little bit about that
well the problem when you look at it
from a single staircase map is there's
no viability of rotation so we've added
a second set of stairs that go all the
way up all the way down which allows for
greater rotation then you add the traps
and then you add the balconies on the
outside it allows the attackers and the
defenders to rotate really quickly
depending on how they want to play the
bomb sites yeah I want to point out
really quickly we're gonna get into all
of those bomb sites and in just a moment
but I wanted to point out that design
the art design you and your team and the
art team at back in Montreal have done
an incredible job at revamping this map
the art team again have done an
absolutely superb job you know it feels
like her effort
it doesn't feel like it's a completely
alien space it feels like Hereford it
looks like Hereford it's got the same
thematic
the same feel like Max and the art team
in Montreal did an absolutely superb job
of course its England so they made it
rain which kind of a little bit that
it's raining it doesn't rain in England
all the time but you know it's it's it's
you know it's grim sky it's raining you
know yeah it fits really well with the
operation that you feel it you feel the
ambience you feel the environment and I
think you know I got tweeted that when
we first revealed that this this map one
of the tweets that I received was you
know it feels as though as as that would
fit as though I imagined exactly how it
would be in the books so you know it's
going back to a little bit of that
cinematic step that we really wanted to
introduce with Herefords the the old art
style was a little bit grey all over the
place
heart-to-heart to do a lot of call-outs
on that as well it's impacted gameplay
and I think players will be replenished
time it's definitely many more thematic
SAR very strong and it's great to hear
that people feel that when they see this
map now they feel like it's come from
the books you know that's what we strive
to achieve at all times is to go through
and make it feel like a real living
breathing place know and like I said the
art team did an amazing job on this and
I'm super proud to have worked on the
map with the other designers yeah
alright so let's go into the spawns and
into these into this building and break
it down bomb site by bomb site because I
really want to get into the guts of this
but let's start with the spawn points
what has changed with the spawn points
nothing much has really changed for the
spawn points you've still got control
tower the shooting range and the
Spitfire courtyard so that will feel
very familiar to anyone that's played
Hereford and hopefully the entire
community has so nothing's really
changed the approaches have changed
because obviously the outsides
completely changed the inside change the
approaches have changed a little bit but
they're very pretty well sheltered and
they're very good approach lines first
in terms of those approaches you know a
lot of those elements a lot of those
objects that were there before have
completely
been redesigned yes everything's been
redesigned cool all right so let's get
into the guts of this building Jeremy I
know you're excited to break it down
we're gonna be going floor by floor
starting with the third floor down all
the way to the basement so let's start
with that third floor bomb sites and we
have ammo and tractor on the third floor
how you got a tractor on the third floor
I is beyond me but you know break down
the strategy for this imoen tractors
actually one of the bomb sites that we
had she had the most trouble with it
wasn't very viable we had to rework in a
few times it's a very open space but not
too much cover so it does make it quite
tricky to actually go through and defend
there's no direct access really to a
bomb site so as per usual you have to
commit to the bomb site to actually go
through and be able to attack it or you
know attack it fully it's really
interesting because you're looking for
the attackers to come from the balcony
or from the two stairs that come up yeah
and we're gonna to be taking a look at
that that entranceway in just a moment
but you know that's that strategy of
defending from the balcony from the
outside from the top how is that for you
as a designer to really design that that
defense point it's actually really fun
to design something like that and
there's a few little ticks and tips and
tricks you can actually use as an
attacker
remember there is a drone vent up on the
roof so if you need to drone that bomb
site or if you need to join any bombs
like you can go top-down or bottom-up
but what makes this so fun is there's so
many avenues for the attackers to come
at you from the stairs or from the
balcony so you can find out the
defenders quite easily from the stairs
or even the roof there I feel like
there's gonna be a lot of external
rotations on this map I think this bomb
site I think you defined a lot of people
if they need to rotate they'll go up on
the roof and come down and rappel on the
other side for sure and now that balcony
is really important as well talk to us a
little bit about that balcony why is
that there the balcony is there to allow
another option for the attackers to
actually come in but also have another
avenue for defense because if you've
only got two sets of stairs in a couple
of windows it's not really enough you
know fun gameplay
but you throw that balcony into the mix
it really does mix it up and it's a very
very tense ball
like to defend one of the words that you
described this bomb site was absolute
chaos
it's it's so much fun even when we play
testing it internally like you can hear
the hear the team screaming like just
just because sometimes you just get here
and you just don't expect to know where
it's coming from and it just comes from
every side and there's not much covering
you're just running for house it's so
much fun to play I think the community's
gonna love this planet I mean that's
where we always start with on their Maps
or operators is fun right yeah that's
that's what you're trying to achieve
here all right let's move on to the
second floor
we have kids room and master bedroom on
the second floor let's take a look at
these bomb sites here tell us a little
bit about the strategy behind defending
and attacking the second floor kids room
master bedroom is a really good area to
go through and play it's it's a very
viable bomb site it's an awful lot of
fun you see in the kids bedroom there's
the bunk beds and there's the bomb right
on the side and it's really fun to try
and defend the bomb like if you got
someone staying back and trying to hold
the area and is there's a lot of options
to actually extend your defense on this
floor for sure yeah you mentioned that
verticality yeah that verticality comes
in play on the second floor really
really importantly because you have
those hatchets you have those
line-of-sight floors on both sides yeah
on this on the floors and the ceilings
so how are players are going to be
defending against that verticality on
this floor it's it's a it's a tricky one
I haven't quite figured out myself yet
but you generally find people just there
are areas that aren't actually
destructible floor and you'll find a lot
of people will be rotating through those
areas knowing that they've actually got
a little safe passage for a period of
time but you can get shot like you said
from above or from below so you're never
really you're never really safe yeah I
think that's one of the key things on
this new rework is that verticality and
we will see it throughout the map and
entirely on that third floor on that
second floor and now let's move on to
the first floor where we have kitchen
dining room tell us about the strategies
that you'll see on kitchen dining room
and what has changed on the first floor
Jeremy okay
what's changed in the first floor is
that there was that massive choke that
massive hallway where you have the choke
point at the entrance and the choke
point at the stairs
and chaos in the middle so is that still
there no that's not there anymore we
weave the entire floor plan for the
entire map has changed but you know
obviously you don't want choke points
when you're designing a map
so we've taken as many of the choke
points you know as you can actually out
of the map so the corridors not straight
you've still got quite good
line-of-sight you know with the mirror
wall is actually really quite fun
actually on all the bomb sites it's
really fun but I find that playing a
mirror on this site is really nice and
because you're going to destruct destroy
the walls between the two bomb sites it
allows for really fast rotations but it
is the ground floor so you've also got
the problem of you're defending the
windows because the attackers can get to
you really quickly all thinking should
come through the placement up the stairs
you know so it's it's one of those it's
one of those bomb sites that are it is
really fun to play but you need to get
your strats down really well to figure
out what you're gonna do in
communication is key speaking of coming
in through the basement let's take a
look at our basement map or basement
bomb sites where we have brewery and
fermentation room now as a UK man
yourself I am very pleased to see that
there's a brewery in the basement of
Hereford yes I'm sure the SAS drink a
fair amount of beer it's a great firm
attic you know when it's cold and rainy
outside you want to drink some beer
basements really fun there's a couple of
big objects for the fermentation tanks
that are bulletproof so you've got a
long line we can actually shoot through
and go back and forth which is really
nice and one of the key things is we're
taking a look at the Otago and tunnel
right now which is a new addition why
did you add this tunnel what is so key
about this if you put a basement in the
ground and you and you've only got two
sets of stairs it's not fun because you
know exactly where the attackers where
they come from they're gonna come from
the stairs so you can't do that because
it won't be fun and then we'll have the
same problem again with the original he
referred which is they're only going to
play the one Bible bomb so it's easy to
defend right you add the tunnel on the
outside and then you add the garage
which is off on the side as well it
allows the attackers to actually have
more ways to actually enter the building
and it makes for a much much more
interesting defense as well much for
answering interesting defense and a much
more interesting map because you you
have that access point and people can
enter it the attackers can enter it
through the base line to attack the
first floor and they can use it as of
course on that basement and approach as
well but that becomes so crucial
of course it's it's one of those things
where you know when you watch the pros
plays and you want to watch you know
rank level players play you watch them
droning a lot of the time and this map
allows for droning from the basements
you can go through and check for the
Roma's and it allows from roaming from
the top as well so you can actually come
down with your drone from the roof and
you're in relative safety on the roof
and your relative safety outside when
you're down by the basement as well so
it allows anyone that's playing a
roaming game and droning out game to a
key allows them a lot of options for
sure a lot of option a lot of creativity
a lot of strategy that I'm sure we'll
see once this hits the test server but
before we close out hair furred how
would you what would are some of the key
takeaways that you want the community to
know about the most important thing when
you approach this map is remember it's a
brand new map but the two stairwells are
definitely key the drone vent on the
roof and definitely the balcony on the
side because you know they're the three
elements that are really going to allow
players to actually get in and explore
the map quickly and get to their
objective fast why did you feel so it's
so necessary to add that second stair
well it's mainly for navigation and flow
no.1 when we designed maps in Montreal
we look at navigation flow verticality
and viability of bomb sites one set of
stairs isn't enough for a navigational
flow and it doesn't allow for very good
rotations so obviously you need to add a
second set of stairs now when you've got
two sets of stairs you're essentially
creating two choke points where you can
get stopped quite quickly so if you add
the balcony as another option you know
it allows people to run around and roam
much easier so it allows the verticality
in the roaming game to be much stronger
yeah of course as we also wrap up with
the balcony the balcony becomes that
amazing amazing external approach for
the attackers and a nightmare potential
nightmare for the defenders as well I
wouldn't say nightmare I'd say it's just
it's kind of fun because when you get it
right it feels so good
so but but when you're slightly off your
game and you're not hitting your shots
yeah it's it can even lead to a world of
pain very quickly that's just showing
attackers can utilize that approach and
get cut off or get a frag in the early
game as a as they're you know picking
off the defender in that area the
guarding of that area they can really
use that utilize that and take that to
their advantage it's it's it's really
interesting I'm really looking forward
to seeing the way the strats come out
and the way people play the game I've
been watching people in the free buy
area playing the map and it's really
interesting to see what they're doing on
the map because it's beautiful I've
heard an incredible feedback from
everybody that I've talked to here at
Paris about the map about the operators
and we'll get to the operators in just a
moment but that is your first look at
hair furred base I'm so excited for
players to discover that balcony
discover those stairs discover the
verticality they were and fewer spawn
Peaks as well Oh which I'm sure a
million is very sad to hear oh there's
definitely less there's definitely less
spawn pigs for short like you know we
shot we shut those down for early in
production because yeah no one likes
porn Pixar no one likes to get ideas
everyone well that is your look first
look at Hereford base coming your way to
the test server on Monday August 20th
that's tomorrow you'll get to play this
tomorrow on the test server on PC so
without further ado let's get into our
operators we have our two new operators
maverick and Clash and to introduce them
let's take a look at this quick video
from Ubisoft News in operation grim sky
things are heating up and getting
electric as two new operators one
attacker and one defender join Team
rainbow where they'll put their training
to the test on a completely reworked
Herefords a s-- the gentlemen quietly
burning a hole through this reinforced
wall is maverick a one armored
three-speed operator maverick comes
equipped with the Surrey torch
unlike thermite and Habana were able to
make law
holes and reinforced walls maverick is
able to burn his way through barriers
and create holes of various sizes it'll
take up nearly all of your torches fuel
to create a hole you can actually move
through but what maverick excels at is
cutting out small sneaky windows
creating sight lines nearly anywhere
Mussoorie torch is able to melt just
about anything like breakable walls
reinforced walls castle barricades
deployable shields floor hatches
maestro's evil eye and even defending
operators this is one of the most
dynamic gadgets around capable of
melting holes of many shapes and sizes
in the defending teams reinforcements
any attacker can take advantage of
Mavericks handiwork but with the new AR
1550 or the m4 assault rifle in hand he
does just fine on his own Mavericks
torch is handy for eliminating enemy
gadgets as well play peek-a-boo with
bandit batteries and mute jammers to
clear the way for thermite or Habana or
just open a little door for twitches
drone to roll through and take care of
business for bigger holes you'll need a
steady hand move across a wall too
quickly and the torch won't have enough
time to cut through too slowly and
you'll waste your limited fuel supply
aiming down sights will help you
maintain a consistent speed while
ensuring those crisp clean cut outs and
while it's not completely silent
Mavericks torch is pretty quiet opening
up possibilities for stealth subterfuge
and so so many deadly new sightlines
defenders will have to be extra vigilant
against small breaches but maverick
needs to stay sharp as well the surrey
torch isn't much of a weapon and it's
two meter range leaves maverick
vulnerable while he's crafting his
latest work of art a quick call-out from
a defender could leave you vulnerable to
a flanking attack so be sure to deploy
that Claymore wisely or you could use it
deviously planting it by a small breach
hole as a trap for careless enemies with
all these new holes appearing in your
defenses it's nice to have a defender
who offers some extra protection that
defender is clash the first shield
bearing defender in siege her
indestructible CCE shield covers the
entire front of her body and comes with
a built-in taser that slows and damages
enemies within range making her a
formidable obstacle her taser operates
on a charge and will refill whenever
it's not active mind your battery level
though if you drain the shields charge
completely you'll have to wait until it
fully recharges to use it again to whip
out her sidearm weapons clash has to put
her shield on her back where it will
still offer some protection just like
other shields do she can certainly get a
kill in a pinch but her main focus is
crowd control
as a former riot officer with the
British MPs clash is no stranger it's a
close-quarters action slowing down the
attack makes the clock work in your
favor while drawing your enemy's
attention has the added benefit of
making them more susceptible to flanking
attacks from your teammates and let's
not forget one of the most powerful
things a shield can do block enemy fire
has that pesky Maverick cut a hole into
a reinforced wall and exposed your
entire team plug it up with clash
sometimes physically blocking an enemy's
progress is your best play but don't be
afraid to use your protection to your
advantage with three armor and one speed
clash might seem like the furthest thing
from a roamer but her shield allows her
to be in spaces where defenders normally
fear to tread stroll outside for some
early game scouting and use your map
knowledge to roam in areas where
attackers can't easily get behind you
your p1 OC or SP SMG sidearms mean
enemies can't safely turn their back on
you but even with your shield up you're
not invincible
Thatcher can temporarily disable the
Taser with his EMP grenades and cap e
taos asphyxiating bolts can do serious
damage to the slow-moving flash even
with her shield equipped furthermore
clash cannot melee with her shield in
fact if an enemy manages to melee her or
if she gets hit with a concussion
grenade from Zofia
she'll drop her guard momentarily and be
partially exposed
but Clash is not one to be vulnerable
for long and getting through her
stalwart defense will prove to be a tall
order operation grim sky is set to
seriously shake things up on both sides
of the conflict for more on Rainbow six
siege subscribe to our YouTube channel
and be sure to check out new zubi soft
calm
and there it is that's your first look
at flash and maverick and now I'd like
to bring in emelian LeMay game designer
on Rainbow six how you doing man
and then Granderson thank you very much
you're gonna be breaking down all the
redesign reasons behind these two
operators but let's first break down who
they are let's get to know clash clash
who is she well clash is someone will
believe to fight for the good coast
she's she puts team play above all else
she is resolute she stop with it and
she's a bit arrogant but extremely loyal
arrogant but loyal I like her already so
how does her gameplay play out obviously
we saw a little bit in that footage but
how did you design her so the ID was
indeed to bring a shield in defense
which Knight seems and sounds terrifying
and that makes a lot of sense very scary
but ever since release siege we had to
win half year of experience to try to
pick what we liked from the shield
gameplay and adapt that to the notion of
shielding defense and that was a long
process but we think we found something
interesting
so you took like what you like the most
from Montaigne and what you like the
most from blitz sort of married them
together in in clash a little bit yeah
kind of that and at the same time is
like you have to both take what you like
for the shield and also think it's a
defence shoulder he doesn't have to push
the side she does she just has to stand
there and prevent them from pushing so
we focused the shield mostly on the
defensive aspect that was super key on
the team play aspect but removed a lot
of elements of lethality mainly this is
our first defense operator with a shield
why are we introducing this now to the
game well we definitely want to explore
new areas of gameplay never seemed like
as much as we can and I'll expand on the
thing that already exists that also
bring some new things new fun things to
play around matter clash in every
situation was mostly we need someone who
couldn't ring a new way to play as a
team and definitely since she is very
low lethality she really needed team a
to do the job with her she needs to
communicate a lot and that's what we
like about flash so you you would
describe her more as like a team play
operator than anything else right yes
definitely above all else above all us
why is she so good at creating team
player
in team plays situation well we do
believe that even though she's three amo
and one speed and she's carrying a
shield so she's fairly slow but the way
we see her play at least in the early
round is to move around the bomb side
move around the map and collect
information because she's so resilient
that you can access places that other
cannot however it she gets too far away
from a teammate since she's not capable
really - and defend herself that well
she will be very very weak with the
enemy team so she needs at the same time
to be very well aware of the position of
the enemy and her teammates right so
because she has low lethality she needs
a little bit of backup a little bit of
support before she pulls out her weapons
and I mean looking at her she really is
strong at gathering that Intel as you
mentioned would you sort of describe her
as like a roaming anchor that's
something you would say it's kind of
accurate yeah I would say it's like this
- stage in the round where you would be
like this roaming of support from her
like the first part of the round will
being information a lot moving a lot
gathering information and then maybe
come back to site in second half to try
to use a shield a Taser shell that will
slow down your enemies to prevent the
push and prevent the enemy from planting
of diffuser and accessing is the
objective
yeah the Taser is really one of the key
elements of her gadget it keeps players
at bay it keeps them that distance is
that really important for clash yes it's
it's really key because like I said
contrary to other shelled every shield
we have especially blitz but also even
even not an orange juice they want to
close the gap to you their long runs are
not that effective but they want to
close the gap they want to get to your
face
however clash is the exact opposite
she's a shill in defense we need to
think this the other way around she will
do everything in our power to prevent
you from begin to close range
because she is extremely weak at close
range she will try to do the exact
opposite and new player that will
discover flash after playing all the
shields will need to get that in the
mind as well when the see clash do not
run away try to close the gap try to
rusher try and close that gap in order
to get that melee off so that you can
have that semi guard break
now you mentioned circling back a little
bit you mentioned team play that is one
of the key aspects of clash how do you
think she's gonna fare in competitive
play here I'm very curious about that to
be honest it's always
extremely difficult to plan what's going
to happen in pro league since York rail
a lot of team player do expect to see
her it's it's a big sacrifice to bring
clash with you because you love to lose
again entirely but almost and if you do
that you need to make the most out of
capability and that implies a lot of
team play so I do see her being used
there as booming supporting the roamers
preventing access to the side laying the
time playing the time a lot which is the
most important resource in the game
potentially that's where she's gonna
shine the most because you are gonna
have that communication that
coordination between players and have
structured strategies around clash where
she's not only you know defending and
blocking a site push but you can push
outside push outside the map a little
bit and gather that Intel gather that
Intel to the team and then also provide
a little strategy of maybe having a
defender behind her in order to see
through the shield because that shield
is see-through that's the first
see-through shield we're introducing why
do you think that's so key to climb well
the theis true aspect of her shield is
real interesting it it gives the
defender it's not like a mirror in the
center it's it through both ways but
still it kind of is this movable mirror
that you can move through the map the
bigger behind I get some kills so this
is the first aspect second aspect is a
very big shield and it's terrifying the
psychological effect of saying clash
will refocus the attention of the
attacking team on them and this is where
team play comes back here because as
soon as attention is focused on you now
at the time for ela and Niger and anyone
free speed around to get the kills
against the attacking team right get
that kills from behind her as you know
she seems like a really good solid
support character low lethality but she
still has gun right this is the Rainbow
six siege let's take a look at her
loadout what is she packing so yeah a
primary with on ease the shilts and she
cannot to have a Saitama move that
chilled it's a big shield and you cannot
have to shot them with it but it's the
same way that like plates and Montanan
have their prime primary as like as
their shield yes but they have their
side I'm with the children she can out
she can but if she plays the shield in
the back she can access the items which
are both great weapons we have a handgun
and the first burst fire weapon of the
game two bullets both of them come
equipped with
sites and really good site by the way
they're not very they're not don't we
never be as powerful other in SMG but
they can do the job if you're like the
last survivor or if the enemy team
realizing that from another threat look
away yeah now is your turn to shine in a
pinch when you really need to just get a
kill she can pull those out yeah now
let's go on to our secondary gadgets as
well because she has a few very useful
yes the secondary gadgets are definitely
tailored to fit the two roles we
mentioned there's this first part of the
round where you move around and then you
have the impact name that allows you to
create holes in your defense to have the
defenders run around Oh even if you are
supported by your own or make those
rotation on a bench yeah second gadgets
more the second part of their own if you
want to prevent the push you have the
barbed wire which would increase your
ability to prevent the enemy from
pushing the bombs that's a really deadly
combination there with the barbed wire
plus the shock yes
that's gonna be tough to counter
speaking of the counters though she is
countable she does have weaknesses a lot
of people came up to me when they first
saw Clash they were like you know I
think Shields ROP I think they are
unbalanced so how have you balanced
clash well she has like again we add a
learning and it's two and a half years
of having least running around and all
and now we think that we found some ways
to have clashed being very interesting
to play but also not as frustrating to
play against and the most of those
counter comes from that she cannot melee
you cannot melee you at short range
that's not possible for us so but you
can you will trigger this semi guard
break that can move the shell to the
side and allow you to shoot her legs
however that means you need to get too
close branch to do that we can use
stature crystals EMP will disable the
shield and allow you to bypass the Taser
a part of the shield yeah and we also
saw Sofia and we we also saw capitalist
as counters who do you think is the most
the the strongest counter against clash
Katia Tower is definitely the strongest
she's slow she has a shield on top of
that and the fireballs if you blaze it
writes you will kill clash very fast
Caputo is definitely very strong as
clash but Thatcher and Sofia can do a
pretty good job yeah
absolutely so that is a look at clash
coming your way to the test server very
shortly but let's also take a look at
her BTUs that are coming with the launch
of grim sky of course these BTUs are
available with the year three season
pass this is a head-to-toe customization
and they look really cool they're sort
of grim sky themed didn't grim Scott's
tie the sky colored so it's super cool
she her art design is wonderful I love
her it's really amazingly dead-ass yeah
so you'll be able to player tomorrow and
another person that you'll be able to
play is maverick let's go into maverick
who is maverick chameleon well maverick
is an enigma we couldn't even the team
rainbow is his solitaire is very good at
running human mind domme but it's
difficult to know a lot about him he's
very he's very famous for its precise
work though and he's hired at ability
but outside of that standing them he's
an enigma of a man and enigma with his
gadget because that gadget is so cool
how does this gameplay design from your
side so yeah the design there was we
wanted to bring a third hybrid meta that
was key and but we wanted to make sure
that it was very different from termites
and banna and that was a big challenge
and we can't have this idea that those
Mavericks you do a very different role
than those two yeah so why as a designer
as a game designer arepa succeed was it
important for you guys to introduce in a
third heart region why is that important
there is multiple aspects to this
question one of them from covered
display is we introduced Pekin man
recently and despite the fact that the
Kanban booth out we try it rarely
happens we still want to make sure that
we have three options that's the one
thing second thing even more important
to us is the metal bridging role is a
very key role in sage and people that
play that will have limited options just
to and we needed a third one to gave
them new aspect of how to approach a
downside and third on downside maverick
would be extremely really done contrary
to the other two or in combination with
the other two his his gadget is so much
different from them where Habana and
might have this really binary it's
either open or closed maverick has a lot
of creativity what are some of the
strategies that you have seen in your
place sessions well in practice we
introduced maverick as a Habra that was
the key
that's when what we see in the game plan
is very true is it stands between
harbour eager and disabled you have
switched Thatcher Thurmond banner and
it's somewhere in the two because we can
bring him as your main a breacher and
try to make small holes all you can
brimming with thermite to destroy the
penet battery or new channels and you
can use them at with this specific flow
yeah and obviously he is an alternative
to like a cabana and thermite but he has
a lot of those sinners yes and I think
we're gonna see a lot of that gameplay
as well where people are using either
thermite to distract or a again and the
the Maverick would then flank around and
maybe create a couple of kill holes is
that something that you you are
expecting play definitely that would be
if you don't use him necessarily a
little man-boy trailer which should be
rare yeah a sable you have this third
option is three speed is fast and is
gadget is fairly silent so you can just
run around and this noise makes some
tiny owls in the defense beyond them and
when they're watching termites blowing
up the wall that are watching the other
way and then you can get some pretty
sneaky kills yeah again for a
competitive player how do you think he's
gonna play it's really again super
tricky and since it's so creative in its
ability to make whatever whatever he
wants I'm really curious to see what
they're gonna do it doesn't have a lot
of resources in this gadget so not it's
never gonna replace the theremin ivory
banner but it can it's very new role in
to bridging meta and we're gonna see a
lot of interesting thing with maverick
yeah a lot of interesting things a lot
of creativity and let's take a look at
it slow down as well
his loadout is pretty powerful opponent
it's a classic for an attacker I would
say we have a stomach automatic DMR and
we have an assault rifle there's two
very good weapons and the sound design
of this webinar amazing it's free ammo
we're three speed one arm also very very
fast and yes an gun with that but the
most important and interesting thing
about Maverick and his loadout secondary
gadgets secondary gadgets tell us a
little bit about his secondary gadgets
what are this so the Sailor gadgets are
very important for him yes
to claim all and smoke this is two very
different approach to maverick the smoke
is since is a very potent operator since
it cannot really be countered by Newton
bandit
he needs drawback and the drawback is it
takes time a lot of time to make your
holes you're exposed you're very close
to the rule the enemy team see the torch
through the wall so they can challenge
you and try to kill you so it's pretty
tricky as a maverick to trying to find a
hole if the enemy team is aware but you
can use your smoke grenade you make
Daniel Telus program and hide most of it
and then you can finish the job or you
can have someone peeking that hole like
a glass peeking through the spoon yeah
hole a lot of a lot of options oh man a
black beard six cup of that that would
be really really key I mean and also I
mean it's great counter against mirror
as well as we saw in that in that
trailer where you can have a twitch
growing role in and and and yeah open
those mirror mirror holes those are have
become so important I mean we see mirror
as like a great band rate as well as
blues bottom also at the bottom of the
of the world are also very key you can
have a drone go there yeah so Twitter on
fact that will interview the mirror but
this is where the second gadget comes
into play you can place the claymore
mine there and create some insanely
because Nicky traps sanely sneaky traps
and now let's move on to his counters
how do you stop it well there is again
the since is somewhere between disabler
and method Richard is not in the same
cantaloupe as Donna and thermite
obviously however removing this contra
meant we had to do think of a lot of
drawbacks and as we mentioned we need to
be very close to the wall the attiny
knows the other and your base flow and
the holes appears as as you go so anyone
that just pick the whole can shoot you
alright anyone that tossed a c4 through
the hole they know you're like a metre
and a half behind it so you're gonna die
with that you either you need to sneak
and do this discreetly or any teammate
to cover you now million we were
introducing operator that doesn't have a
counter directly from another gadget
there's no bandit no mute counter don't
you think it's a little silly that the
counter against him is just shooting him
in the head well that's the main Connor
against anyone to be honest but I
understand the concern I I just
encourage it whether to play it and see
goes in the sand that we did were very
careful about implementing drawbacks to
these powerful gadgets so the drawbacks
the main one being that you can
immediately see him and that makes his
holes and so it's a little bit difficult
to pull off some of those and it doesn't
have enough resources anyway to make
holes as big a thermite would do and
even Adana so it will be you can have
enough resource to make something that
can go through but it would use most of
it and it will never be this big hole
when molten can push for me right you
can can't create that a huge hole for
him great so that is a look at maverick
now let's take a look at his BTUs as
well that are coming with the launch of
grim sky once again these are head to
toe BTUs customization items that will
be day one
once the grim sky launches and you can
get them with a year three season pass
so that is a look at clash and maverick
coming your way to the test server on
Monday August 20th tomorrow which is
really exciting
Amelia before we move on to our next
segment with going breaking down some
features that are also coming in grim
sky how would you describe clash
maverick in just a few words just just
to wrap it up well well that's easy
actually because clash I use the world a
lot and this is key and I'm saying it
again team play team play template
simply and maverick considering the way
the gadget function creativity
creativity creativity I cannot wait to
see what players are gonna come up with
because there are always smarter than us
they find strategies way better than
what we do and end up 35 million and
there's 35 million of them as well who
are coming up with strategies it's a
really incredible I cannot wait for you
guys to test out classroom average but
there is also a lot more coming with
grim sky and let's break down some of
those features right now the first one
being the myth the weapon sight
misalignment fix that we we we covered
this in a blog post earlier but what
exactly are we fixing with this weapon
site misalignment well without going
into too many details in here it's it's
a fix we've been working on for a very
very long time very happy that it gets
to into the game now basically
oftentimes when you shoot with a weapon
the middle of the screen and
scope would not be aligned and you
sometimes you would feel like I shot the
head but no the scope was on the head
but not the middle of the screen so the
bullet missed now it's no longer the
case every single moment in there in the
rate of fire of your weapon the center
of the screen is the line so bottom line
though the bullet will go where your
reticle is pointing yes that's a very
key part it's like usually with that was
not happening all the time and now it
will be wonderful to some to the case
yeah and I gotta ask this seems like a
very important fix that we're
introducing why it takes so long it's
it's it's tricky it's the problem is
like when we see that for the first time
like more than a year ago we think okay
let's try to find it an easy fix to that
but there was none and every fixed word
to investigate meant going deep down
into the the systems we have in place in
the in the core aspect of the game and
it was much more heavy and long that we
expected a took hold of time we iterate
also we tried a few things that not
necessarily worked this version were
very proud of and we confident it will
function we saw a ton of recoil patterns
on test servers so this definitely took
a process but it's finally coming with
room yes finally yeah also coming with
grim sky is the new Idol pick so no long
streamers no longer have to play as
recruit when they run away to the
bathroom were are getting another drink
or whatever I always see that on stream
and I'm really excited about this change
where it will automatically select a
random operator once you if you don't
select an operator so yes you know the
comfort of life reality of life it's
happened to every one of us yeah Devin
always and that's pretty comfortable the
interesting aspect of that is it came
from a different feature it can because
we needed that for pick and then because
there is no recruiting taken man and
playing picking Ben you're like yeah but
that's cool let's just bring this right
away into rank and then a casual in the
rest of the game so this is how we like
this big feature that might have meant
for different purposes end up just
joining the rest of the game yeah
absolutely
now we have the map rework but we also
have a map buff as well Jeremy tell us
about the map buff well everyone knows
and loves consulate right oh we love it
well we've gone through and we've
reworked consulate you'll see the before
and afters here we've gone through
redone the art we've gone through added
another bomb site to the map and we've
gone through and looked at the most
important thing which was the early
kills in the spawn fakes and it looks
absolutely amazing yeah the crowd is
reacting right now what do you think why
did why do you think it was really
important to do these tweaks these map
all they really do like from that baby
doing it was adding the main thing was
adding a fourth bomb pop it away there
cheering yeah
artyom Montreal should be super proud
because they did a super job yet again
but adding adding a fourth bomb into the
into the map was actually one of the key
things we wanted to do because you know
for bombs makes four-foot bombs it was
more fun he also makes the map an awful
lot more viable for you know ranked and
prob'ly yeah it was removed from
competitive play and and this is one of
the reasons why it was it maybe I don't
know well no I know a lot of people who
have been complaining about it because
of some of these issues that you're
fixing but but yeah but one of the
aspect we had in mind as well when
Willie speak and I need to introduce
rotation to three bomb sites and we
remove map that didn't have a fourth one
right
however consulate was too good to be
removed and then those guys just catch
off on problem with very well so so we
had added a fourth bomb site to make it
you know more viable and more
competitive so it's you know it's soon
out now it's better it's it's prettier a
few things have moved around a little
bit you know but it's you know it's like
a comfy pair of slippers you like don't
be scared it's still the same map it's
perfectly fine bets it plays better it
looks better and it's absolutely superb
yeah absolutely
now another feature that we just
introduced because of maverick is the
new hatch destruction rework million
tell us a little bit about why you guys
introduced this well that's also a thing
we had in mind a very long time ago when
we released
it felt not right that hatch was binary
that hatch would be destroyed or not and
that's it so what we wanted to do for
wine and that now maverick allows us to
do is this semi destruction that means
that if you want to destroy a hatch with
thermite no problem oh wait thermite
will always blow the hatch but Habana
you'll need six but that's exactly you
need your six pallets it doesn't sound
like a big difference but if the rammer
is around and gets a few shots on your
pallets then you need to use another of
your resources to get the hatch done
yeah or you can have maverick come by
and finish this exactly Maverick can
come by if his job it does if it does
deal enough damage to the hatch it could
be destroyed also so it can deal with
hatch as well but you can also make
those sneaky holes and kill people below
now we've had we've outlined a lot of
these features on our blog Rainbow six
comm we also have a ton more coming with
grim sky including two-factor
authentication for ranked we want we
want you guys to protect your accounts
protect those accounts from hackers
so activate two two-factor
authentication on your accounts we also
have our six fix where you can go and
report bugs report any issues but we
have one more surprise for you and that
is the elite skin we have the frost
elite skin coming with operation grim
sky and here you're taking a look at
proc elite of course the elite skins are
premium skins that are available with a
full head-to-toe redesign of the
character plus a weapon skin a charm
and that often victory screen animation
I'm so pumped for players to to try that
out and of course operation grim sky
launches tomorrow on the test server
Monday August 20th you'll be able to
play it you'll be o play clash maverick
the new map rework for hair furred
you'll be able to play the new buff for
conflict I'm so excited
and thank you guys so much for joining
me Jeremy and Billy and thank you guys
so much thank you thank you this yeah
that's great
thank you ever on a romping siege are on
the world and thank you one is this
amazing room it's a fantastic extreme
and ever edible celebration of siege but
do not touch that browser
we have a ton more content coming up for
you we have eg vs. g2 but first we have
a live performance right after this